[Music]
okay so I'll start with a quick recap of
what we were doing last time and then
carry on and tell you what we'll do
today we proved certain things we proved
that the volume of the deep sphere
three-dimensional sphere all points of
length less than or equal to one goes
down as the goes to infinity and in fact
they're some taught X is some constant
to the D divided by D to the D over 2
and so it goes to 0 I'm to do this we
use the Gaussian integral and we needed
a to prop I won't go through the proof
again but we needed to properties of the
Gaussian or the integral so one was
radial symmetry so it depended only on R
the distance from the origin and to was
it splits into the coordinate and we
that's only at a Gaussian that can do
that so even though it looked like I
pulled this function out of the Hat it
it was for a reason right and we proved
also that for a uniform random point X
from the unit sphere we have that the
probability that the length of X 1 the
first component this is the distance
from the equator if u is greater than C
over root D goes down as e to the minus
C squared so we prove that so here's a
little sort of general thing I didn't
state last time but many quantities like
x1 the absolute value of x1 right the
first coordinate is a random variable
then X pick uniformly at random from the
unit ball such random variables have
very well behaved tails they have
exponentially dropping tails that is to
say they they drop off exponentially as
we move to multiples they expected that
so as soon as you take twice thrice or C
times the expected value it goes down as
we to the minus C or e to the minus C
squared often e to the minus C squared
so the the e to the minus x squared is
an important function because it's a
Gaussian right and we'll see that
several times that'll come up
so I times call this the law of large
dimensions
it's like law of large numbers but
basically having very or having many
dimensions you sort of like having many
independent variables sometimes so
behaves like that now to gives another
proof of one and also leads to some
puzzles that we discussed a little bit
but it's worth understanding so by Union
bound we saw that at least half the
volume of the sphere lies in a cube of
this side and we draw a picture and the
picture looks sort of confusing in a way
because all I'm saying is here is our
cube and half the volume of the cube is
here but I already proved there half the
volume of the cube is also there right
so apparently they don't seem to
intersect but they do of course they
intersect both facts are true and you
should just write down algebraically
what happens and you'll see that that's
not a problem so 2 also implies the
equator also implied that samples x and
y from the sphere or nearly orthogonal
if they are independent and we proved
that for many samples ok and it we also
saw how to generate uniform random
points from the hyper sphere using
gaussians we the intro to that was
rejection sampling will not be good
right because the cube is much larger
than the sphere in fact that's a general
phenomenon high dimensions if you wanted
to uniform random samples from a lot of
other things which got here right it's
you cannot do rejection sampling in
general in d dimensions you cannot in
close even a sphere let alone other
objects in some imposing thing which is
nice and not much greater volume in two
and three dimensions you can put it in a
square or cube and from which you know
how to draw samples because the
independent coordinates but you can't do
that in either way ok so that's a recap
now today I'm going to start today's
lecture today basically I'm going to
prove a concentration result for
something random variables it's it's
for bleep ed ecologically I thought a
lot about what's the right result to
prove from which I can derive all the
results that we need like Chernoff
bounds I'll tell you what they are if
they are not familiar turnoff bounds and
other concentration things so I'm going
to tell you that but first let's just
start with the central limit theorem
right I'm not going to prove this I mean
you you should you've probably all seen
a proof but at least you know the speed
should know the statement so if you have
independent identical random identically
distributed they don't have to be
identical that's not that important
independent is important for this the
expected value 0 each of them the
variance is Sigma squared then the
quantity write 1 over root n is the
right normalization that is because if I
sum these n things vary in systems up so
the variance of this is n times Sigma
squared if I divide by root n the
variance becomes Sigma squared right so
it tends to a distribution it converges
to the normal which means they're all
Sigma squared this is only a limit
statement what we are trying to what we
are going to try now is to get
statements that hold for every n because
for us to use
we need that further this limit
statement have some problems it's not a
uniform limit so we it's generally not
immediately useful but that's going to
be the guide of what we want to get
right simply limit theorem so one remark
you cannot get this if only the second
moment is assumed to be finite
centimeter needs only to assume the
second moment is finite right so if the
third moment can be in you need not be
finite so for instance if you have the
density probability Oh random variable x
equals x over X cubed sorry a little bit
that has a finite second moment that's
fine
doesn't have a finite third moment but
that's still for X greater than one of
them take
[Music]
that's good enough for the central limit
theorem it's not good enough for us so
to get this going it is not sufficient
to assume just second moments for that
particular density it's a power law you
can you can see what happens I won't do
it here but you can do a calculation to
see that in fact you don't get very nice
tail bones
you wouldn't get that's a polynomial the
tail is very fat right so you won't get
very good table okay so so we are going
to look at I'm going to so most of the
lecture today I'll spend in tail bounds
and we'll come back to geometry either
at the end of today or the next lecture
and start looking at Gaussian annulus
but this tail bound is going to be quite
useful right first mark of any chord
just a recap if you have a non-negative
real-valued random variable then the
probability that that is greater than t
is bounded by something that goes down
to 0 as 1 over T as T gets larger and a
proof is just that we have no
cancellation so the expected value of x
is at least what you get from things
that are greater than T would be true if
the function if the random variable can
take negative values that could cancel
it out and this is not true right so
only for non negative and then chebyshev
you know it's just saying that that the
deviation of the mean is bounded by that
I'm the proof is just by applying take
the square of this and apply which is
non-negative apply Markov and here the
tail bond goes to 0 as 1 over T squared
as T goes to infinity ok it's 50 is good
1 over T squared now can you do better
can you get at a probability that falls
off more than quadratically in TKE
falling off I should have said here more
than quadratically right faster than
quadratic and in fact simple thought
shows you that higher moments would help
so moments are going to play a key role
in this it's often
these tail bones are not always of
course traditionally they were but not
always true by taking moments but I'm
going to do that here so higher central
moment so if you take the odd moment
think of R as higher than two right take
the odd moment so you get one over T to
the R this that is just by applying
Markov inequality to the random variable
X minus the X absolute value to the art
bar usually we want to apply it but are
even so we don't have to worry about the
absolute value signs I'm sorry we don't
worry about the absolute value signs
that right if our if our thought it's
you need to put that but think of it as
a being applied when R is an even
integer
of course our doesn't have to be an
integer for any real right so the higher
the R is the greater the fall rate of
fall you get 1 over t2 they are so that
quantity doesn't depend on T 1 over T is
our that and if R is very high then you
get a very steep fall but for that you
need to bound higher moments you need to
bound higher moments so we'll see how to
do that so I'm going to state now what I
what we call in the book the master tail
down serum only because it's going to
imply tail bounds for churn of gaussians
exponential and all other things
traditionally there's a particular proof
for Chernoff bounds I'll go over that in
a minute
some of you are familiar there are but
then that doesn't work for gaussians
that only Oxford bounded random
variables so traditionally every one of
these one proves separately but this is
going to give it all of them that's the
reason for calling it master so your
independent random variables mean 0
variance at most Sigma squared not
identical right for those that are
interested this actually holds even
without assuming independence it it
falls in a more general context it holds
formatting is
but right now we'll only look at here
we'll look only at independent thing so
I'm going to take some integer s which
is less than n Sigma squared over 2 or
whatever reason and here the crucial of
something I'm going to assume the art
moment if R is odd this could be
negative so I put absolute value sign
does not grow faster than R factorial
and this our factorial is crucial and
I'll tell you in a minute why so I'm
this part of the this lecture is going
to be fairly technical because I'm going
to have to prove this right so but the
point here is moments only grow as at
most R factorial times Sigma squared
number one number two I don't assume all
moments exist only certain up to a limit
so it's possible that beyond that the
moments don't exist fever I'm certainly
not necessarily bounded so the gist of
this is the odd moment grosses at most R
factorial and the theorem this is the
theorem I will prove this which will
take us a little bit of time will prove
this is a tail bound the probability
that X greater than any number a
morality is not very big very large
deviations this is not valid but as long
as the A's at most this falls off as e
to the minus a squared times something
let's chair it that something for a lit
before we prove this so each of these
random variables had variants upon Sigma
squared if I add up n of them the
variance is n Sigma squared at most so
an upper bound on the variance or that
should be x one upper bound on the
variance of X 1 plus X n because they
are independent so if I did have the
central limit theorem type behavior then
this is correct I would have a squared
divided by the variance I'm not worried
about constants the twelve is higher
than what treinta limit theorem will
give you will be two but we are getting
it for all n so within constants
it is like the behavior of the central
limit theorem okay so in some sense the
tails behave like this now they don't
behave like this for very large a but
that's always going to be true so you
should always revisit this little thing
that if I have coin tosses if I toss a
coin I talk send coins with probability
of heads being P so this is viñoly P
each of them then the tails of sum of X
I want to n or not
Gaussian beyond a certain point so CX
squared be on some X so very large
deviations you get only simple
exponential box that's always going to
be a problem right again that requires a
calculation actually doesn't require too
much of a calculation the probability so
in fact I can write this down the
probability that X Y is greater than or
equal to n that means all the points
have to come out to one right is is P to
the N where as if it had been sub
calcium you should be getting an N
squared there which you don't get right
you're only getting that so this is a
Gaussian bound with a correct variance
except for constants you get that now
why do our factorial this I have to
write on the board because I didn't
write it
so intuition about our factorial so many
proofs of tail bounds start by saying
the probability that the random variable
X is greater than or equal to T right
equals the probability that e to the
lambda X is greater than or equal to e
to the lambda T for a positive lambda
for all positive lambda
this is true just because the
exponential function is monotone right
which is less than or equal to the
expected value if either and then the X
minus 9:30
this is Markov inequality right who has
seen a proof that begins like this this
is called the Bernstein method or the
exponential generating function method
is used for Chernov prints right so many
proofs start like this now if X is some
of X I want to end so that's X and then
this factors that's e to the lambda X X
is the sum of X Y factors right it's
just a product I won't do that proof but
that can only work if the exponential
moments exist this is valid only if
expected value of e to the lambda X I
exist otherwise it's not valid and now
if they expand e to the lambda
I'm sorry I should have put that in the
slides but anyway so I do a Taylor
series of this right so then I will get
I use P already so I get I equals 0 to
infinity lambda to the I over I
factorial I'm just doing two exponential
Taylor series
so if expected value of x where I grew
faster than I factorial there's no hope
this series does not converge right so
this method is I mean it may work for
other reasons but this method is not
likely to work right there may be
cancellations but it's not absolutely
convergent so if this grows faster than
so in after them X to the I and then I
factorial the series does not absolutely
converge
no absolutely so then the Bernstein
method this is called the bernstein
method again I won't follow this method
I'm going to I'm going to tell you that
it's better to abandon that and go with
moments that's the spirit of this of
this theorem but if you want to use
Bernstein method it better be true that
it's bounded by I factorial actually it
should be bounded by something slightly
less than I thought of you yeah so yes
or lambda less than 1 so there is some
play with the lambda yes
but ok so yeah there is some play with
the lambda provided I mean if it does
actually strictly false my factorial e
of Sun coming if it grows so if it is I
to something greater than 1
then you would be in some trouble yeah
so yeah so it's essentially more than I
factorial then you'll be in trouble okay
so the other factorial is it agrees with
that but most importantly that statement
this method only what if for every I
however large it bounded by something
like a factorial
whereas here we assume only finite
moments right so this is very crucial so
I I want so typically in this visual
encounter what are called long tail
densities long tail just means the tail
is not exponentially going off so for
instance if you had something everybody
knows what a power law is power law is
just polynomial DK of the density you
had a power law this is still valid you
have finite moments but you will not
have very large limit so this is useful
even then there are finite moment so I'm
going to take it's going to take some
time to prove this 4:05 slide we're
going to go over the proof is elementary
there's nothing phenomenally
sophisticated going on there's some
common Toric's and it's elementary so
the idea is to prove an upper bound on
the art moment and then use that for the
sound then use Markov inequality so I've
got some assists to expand this you do
the multinomial expansion we start with
a multinomial expansion so we get that
so this is just some over all partitions
of R into r1 through RN right is the
exponents of X I mean it's how many
times when you expand this X I occurs
I've just done the multinomial expansion
right and I now take the expected value
of both sides I want the expected value
of this whole thing and I want to take
the expected value of this okay and
something nice happens
so let's try to guess what nice thing
happens and then we'll see it a lot of
these terms have zero expectation so
which terms of zero expectation sorry
yeah whenever whenever our eyes one
right so anytime and our eyes one
independent says that the expected value
of each thing splits up I'll write I'm
writing all this down in a minute
but if RI is 1 the expected value of x
is 0 because that's we started that
right so there are a range is are all
non-negative integers something to all
by independent so first we have to so
first we have to peel off the terms is
independent sets that they factor out
like that and then we get defend any
term are a is 1 the term is 0 since that
0 so our eyes either 0 or at least two
by the way in all these proofs that's
crucial if our a equals 1 terms were
there then you would not get this kind
of result you would not get Gaussian
behavior so okay so now we have to do we
have we're gonna do some combinatoric to
figure out how many terms are alive so
let's consider all of the terms where
each RI is either 0 or 2 or more because
we are only interested in those they are
not interested in the terms where are a
0 or a 1
evie RI has to be 2 or more if it's
nonzero so I assume these are factorial
so the expected value of R this is from
the last slide that was on so like this
oh sorry so if I reach to the alright
power I get only lri factor this was the
hypothesis is the assumption right
therefore that cancels out and you get
this so this actually j is in the
subscript and you get Sigma 2 there so
this is not a - okay so maybe I should
write
it's some over something Sigma to the
twice number of nonzero all right so
that's because every time RA was nonzero
we assumed the boundary that most let's
see this is what I'm applying you get
only a sigma squared every time
ra is nonzero it's important by the way
that Sigma squared it doesn't go up as
Sigma to the alright they will see all
of I mean some thought is required to
make sure that all of those are
important but later you can think about
that right so collect terms which have t
non zeros because they have the same
power of Sigma and call them this this
is a number of this is the set of all n
tuples that have t non zeros this in our
comment oryx and then you get expected
value of x to the or it's this this is
what i'm trying to bond so everything
that has t non-zeros contributes sigma
to the 2t right so and there's an R
factorial little outside so we have to
do all that again
as I said this lecture will be technical
I have to think there are maybe two more
slides so we bound we recruit Lee have
to bound the number of R 1 to R and n
triples adding up two are where it's at
most three of them are nonzero first of
all which T you choose first enter the T
subset one of them is the T that you've
chosen to put nonzero our eyes on once
you fix a subset as a set of key values
which are nonzero each of those values
non zero so it must be at least two so
we allocate two from our budget of our
to each of these all right and then the
rest are allocated arbitrarily again
this is common at oryx right so what is
this so let's go with this the two T I
already have to give each one to at
least so I give two so that
I'm left at our minus 2t and I must
partition the R minus 2t into t minus
one parts I can arbitrarily a lot any
number to each of the parts and that's
what I get this is the number of feet
doubles there's no permutations here
because these are not labeled you have
to think at home make sure that the
proof is correct comment orally but
obviously I've checked that so you get
that J of T is at most this much there's
not a precise estimate but it's at most
this much putting this together you get
that you you get this this for that now
will prove so T only goes up to R over
to important it doesn't go up to our it
goes only apt R over 2 because everybody
which is present with its present at
least as - at the level - right so there
are over two things will prove that T
equals R over 2 is the max of this so
this more or less is going to only look
like our factorial times if I put T
equals R over to there so we get n Sigma
squared to the R over 2 divided by R
over 2 factorial - to our / - okay all
I'm doing is putting T equals R over 2
now if you use Stirling and other things
this is our to the R over 2 so we get an
R and Sigma to the our over to another
two will do this manipulation the next
slide but the moral of the story is very
important the model is the AFT moment of
the some grows only as our over
toothpowder
[Music]
now it requires some thought and I will
do it in the next slide I'll do the
manipulation next life but that is
essential for sub Gaussian behavior so
this is essential for e to the minus x
squared that square there comes from the
origin so if I didn't have or / - I just
had R which is what I would get
trivially so remember I'm bounding
expected value of x I to the art power
so there are n to the our terms and
choose our terms so I might be expecting
an R there
if I did I would not get Gaussian again
it requires a little bit of manipulation
at home to make sure that that you see
that well but we I won't do the
manipulation but I will tell you that
that R over 2 is crucial so now I want
to prove that T equals R over to the max
okay so that's the manipulation for T
less than R over 2 it's easy to see that
HT is an increasing function is
increasing well enough fast enough by a
factor of at least two each time and
therefore the sum is what happens at R
over 2 then as you go down from ro2 it's
falling off geometrically so that's only
a constant at the end of the day you get
this which is what I wrote down there so
what have I got up to this I've got the
most crucial thing I want from all of
this calculation is that the exponent is
all over - not all and that's what is
going to give us the sub Gaussian
behavior
and then you just apply Markov
inequality to get this again you have an
R over two at the top now I wanted eetu
the minus a squared but I've got the art
moment and it turns out that's another
standard calculation this moment bound
applies to every moment R less than or
equal to s if you remember the proof of
chain off then those bounds applied for
every finite R and you choose the best
one that's what we are going to do
except we have a restriction R cannot go
very high okay you cannot get
arbitrarily high moments and then we we
do some calculus and take R to be the
largest even integer less than or equal
to this so this function is minimized at
a certain hour which you can find by
calculus you take the log of that and
minimize that you find by calculus in
the next slide you'll see that and then
R is basically taken to be that value
and that value turns out to be less than
s so it works so this is a statement
that says all of that so we have a
function that looks like x to the x over
two you take log and minimize then you
see that minimized at that point just
differentiate set it to zero its
minimized at that point
so in step two we're using a six and
then at that point you get that you plug
the minimum value and you get this and
which is at most a squid over 12 and
Sigma square that proves it yeah you a
question no so you do have to check all
the details I mean there are several
calculation details that you have to
check but at the end of the day we end
up with that okay so that proves the
master conservation theorem
I'm not going to give you all the
implications I'll give you two
implications of this which will you
one is chain of the other one which
comes next
is a Gaussian annulus theorem which
we'll need for a bunch of which we'll
use for so I think I'll be able to prove
this in the Gaussian analyst theorem
today we'll use the Gaussian analyst
theorem for the random projection
theorem
we'll see the next week which is Johnson
and minstrels so we'll quickly use that
Chernoff bounds how many of you know
channel bounce have seen general many of
you have seen right so okay so we'll
derive that as a as a corollary so if
your independent Bernoulli random
variables here there's one small
restriction for this we applied directly
is that P is not very close to 1 the
probability of heads then qualitatively
the bound says the probability that
deviates by more than n times P is is
this thing again you cannot do very
large deviations only for C at most one
is this valid right so the C squared
behavior stops for a certain CB on so
it's got to see has to be bounded and
you get it simply by applying the
moments or moments are good so simply by
applying the master tail bounds theorem
you would get that so you first Center
it so the expected value 0 the variance
we all know is P times 1 minus P but the
moments are also bounded by basically
that the moments are also at most P
times 1 minus P this actually I wrote
down proof but it's actually simple to
see right beyond the second moment X is
at most one anyway so that's going to be
true okay
we need bounds on moments for our term
right so this is all going to be true so
apply this theorem with a is the 3 and P
how large a deviation you have ok I
think that's all I've said here by the
way there are more details given in the
book right so then the slide
so the usual proof of Channel pounds
again is by going through the Bernstein
method which we raised is going through
the exponential moments right that's
what we do they do apply in this case
the exponential gnomes do exist because
these are finite random variables they
never exceed one so the exponential
moment certainly exists okay now the
next thing I'm going to do is a Gaussian
annulus theorem I'm going to state that
first the exponential moments also exist
here but I'm going to give you a proof
just based on the but but the random
variables are not bounded right it's a
the a Gaussian so they can go to
infinity so some notation you have a
d-dimensional spherical Gaussian this is
the mean of the Gaussian is now both
phase zero because centered at the
origin in D dimensions this is the
identity matrix is the variance
covariance matrix right so for Gaussian
in higher dimensions you describe it by
mean and variance covariance matrix
though so I is the variance covariance
me in statistics is called Sigma right I
mean statisticians are notorious for the
notation so they use Sigma 4 it's a
terrible thing to do but they use Sigma
4 variance covariance matrix right so it
could be more generally it need not be
identity but in this case identity which
means the level curves of the density
look like this right I mean it's
actually so I should say the density
corresponding normal Zi is e to the
minus X blade there's a normalizing
constant 2 pi to the D over
so the density is maximum at zero and
false off okay and their session is for
any beta which is less than rooty at
most so much of the probability mass
again notice the beta squared there lies
between root D most of the mass lies
between root D minus beta and root B
plus beta so oh maybe I should put up
excuse me I should tell you one more
line and then draw a picture so
intuition so the expected value of the
length squared is just a sum of D things
each has expectation one normal 0 1 so
that's B so the mean squared distance is
V radius let's call radius the square
root of the mean squared this is root T
and it says that it should be
concentrated about it expectation that
is roughly what this is saying
[Music]
so let's see what the sixteen so it's
saying that with high probability this
is between root D plus beta and root D
minus beta
so x squared is between D and order base
order to expand this right if I square
this up the second term is more
significant is beta times root T and
then you get be the spell choose a small
small order term so this is more
significant so if I draw a curve so this
is a distance root D and the annulus is
with order one if I instead have
normalize it so that this is distance
one for the Gaussian the annulus is
distance one over Rho T so this is
different from the sphere right the
sphere was concentrated in a smaller
annulus one over D this is concentrated
only in an annulus of it 1 over root T
well of course it is true that there's
some of independent random variables so
you expect it to be concentrated about
its expectation and that's what we'll
prove with this without a term right we
also it's going faster than expected we
have we are already at the twelfth slide
out of 13 so any questions or anybody
wants us let's take a break and drink
water this right here
everything okay so far okay so I'll go
on so what are we doing also we're just
doing the rate R the radius we want to
make sure that 8 minus root T is at most
beta and if it is not then you also have
this right and that's greater than or
equal to beta times root T but R squared
minus G now is the sum of independent
random variables which it means they're
all right Y once y 1 squared is from
there means they're each of them has
mean 0 and they are independent so put X
I equals y squared minus 1 the
probability that X is greater than or
equal to beta minus 3 is what we want to
bound okay but we need to do their esta
moments of X I so we have to run moments
of gaussians I mean this is not a big
deal I can't stand it but let's try to
do that so okay either Y is less than 1
then X is at most less than 1 any power
or Y is greater than 1 then X is that so
in any case you need a case we have that
I've added both cases basically so when
I get that and that I'm just writing
down the Gaussian moment right and I
make this substitution you compute the
moments by converting into it this is a
gamma function because we get e to the
minus Z and Z to some power that's the
gamma function so we get to the s times
s factorial so the variance is at most 8
is a fixed number constant but we do not
have that the estimate so for the
theorem we wanted the asked momenta grow
only as s factorial times the variance
that's not true because
because it grows as where is it it grows
us to the s times s factorial so the
expected value of x I to the earth I
would like no two 3s we want justice
factor we don't want to the s growth so
how will we avoid it and we cannot avoid
it I mean it is it is quite there is a
there is a something to this here
because that's how the gamma function is
right it so up to this point up to the
gamma question was the exact it all
except for a one this was the exact so I
cannot get better than that
but two to the S is lower order than X
factorial right as fact only its roughly
as to the s tunity s is less than that
so it should be manageable so what might
be a trick I mean so what shall I do
so maybe I can ask you the question and
then try to do it
so I would like random variables asked
moment to grow as s factorial basically
but this is growing time as to the s
times s factorial so what's a good way
of trying to do something so I just
divide the random variable I to then the
two layers goes away where the factor of
two is not a problem because we are very
generous with constant factors we don't
care right so that's what will happen
we put W I is equal to X I over two and
everything goes through okay so now
since there are no questions that are 15
minutes we'll we'll have to go over new
stuff which I can do on the board but if
you want you can ask questions instead
okay so now I have to write on the board
because again we are I'm going faster
than I expected so so what change is
asking is that so now if x1 through xn
or normal 0 1 independent iid then I
would like let's say the tail bounce for
yeah so these are independent also and
the moments exist and we should be able
to get a bound fro for these so that you
need a good point you bring up in a way
because for for sum of squares it's a
standard standard thing to try to derive
on this is probably less standard so but
it's also for the moments or moments are
still nice so this also follows yeah
so you do get so I have to work that out
to get what we get okay we'll work it
out so next time maybe I should work
this out and then bring it right friends
we're trying to do but it's fair enough
it's a good question so I mean because
they should apply and get you a bound
get you a bound for this norm also
because these are just independent and
somewhat independent so it's it'll be
more exact than to the S to the s times
their secular sister bound but
qualitatively the to estimate of normal
Gaussian is like s factorial well it's
it's it's odd odd terms only up to 2's
yeah
but the leading term is s to the s see
their centers for this because you have
s things you're multiplying right here
multiplying one three five and so on up
to 2's or two four but there are s
things you're multiplying so it's at
least I guess to the Sterling's formula
or something it's s to the eighth times
our constant to the S qualitatively
that's the correct so let me introduce
Johnson in death sauce which we won't
start proving Nick will prove next time
so the idea is you have points
let's see how do we denote sent it X 1 X
2 up to X n in our team and large there
are many problems in which this is used
but I want to start with one concrete
problem which is estimate all pairwise
systems there are n square of them and
if I take a pair it takes D time to find
the distances right there are D
coordinates have to subtract them and
add so you would seem to take this much
time this theorem what the johnson
lyndon Stross theorem says is that if I
have two points just two points in D
space I can project them down to a much
smaller dimensional space
so that the distance between them in the
projection gives you a good estimate of
the distance between these two there's a
known scale factor but for that it's
it's almost exact so let's see what we
expect here before we go on so I have at
this point let's call this point X this
point why I want to estimate X I minus y
I squared so first we intuitively and
then we'll do the actual proof next time
suppose we choose a random coordinate
system random coordinate system just
means I take the regular coordinate
system and rotate it by a random mark
another way of saying that is I pick the
X 1 axis uniformly at random and then X
2 X is uniformly at random perpendicular
to X 1 and so on so if I took a random
coordinate system intuitively the X I -
why I should all be roughly equal
so roughly X I minus y i all equal
because it was a random coordinate
system right this is not a proof I mean
again we'll prove it carefully so
roughly they should all be equal and
therefore each XY minus y I now if they
are all equal this is this was the
length of X minus y whole square how
would they be related to X minus y there
are D coordinates they are all equal
would I then have 1 over D times this
right
no not quite right because it's
Pythagoras so only the squares add up so
this would be 1 over root T so this is
correct
it turns out to be provable as a theorem
this is what was proved by Johnson in a
thousand a 50 page paper perhaps the
beginning and the difficulty was the
random coordinate system so this was
difficult to do and proved but later
proves did the following very simple
thing vector V what that means is these
picked from the distribution normal zero
I it's a vector right pick from this
then X minus y dot product is of length
1 so what should it be
what should the dot product of this be
in relation to X minus y length based on
that kind of intuition what would you
expect this same one over root T right
because this is again just a random X X
1 X now sometimes it's you need more
solid estimate because we have many
points and we want all pairwise
distances so what Johnson Lyndon
stroeve's originally said is a random
coordinate system right so the biggest
difficulty here was that x2 it we've
appendicular takes 1 and so on but
instead it's enough to pick K of these
which are all independent normal 0 I
they won't be orthogonal but we saw that
there'd be close to orthogonal that's in
laughs that turns out then that X minus
y dot V V I squared summed over this K
would be roughly K or D times X minus y
so this is saying I take K coordinate
directions and take the sum of space
they're not quite they are not
perpendicular but it doesn't matter
right this can be carried out very
easily and we'll see that the proof is
very simple proof is a few lines on the
Gaussian and Euler's theorem so a lot of
sweat goes here into ensuring this
orthogonality of these but that's
unnecessary we can just take gaussian
vectors they need not be quite
orthogonal this is the quantity we can
easily find therefore we might as well
give this so it will prove that we will
prove the next time it's it'll be very
simple again as I told you that this is
true and I'll probably give you a couple
of applications of that